as a sort of preview for how Trump cultists may
react in two weeks when Trump is finally gone?
Yesterday, there was a pro Trump rally in advance
of today's counting of the electoral votes in
Washington, D.C. and it is really something
to behold. This is compelling culturally,
psychologically, politically, scientifically.
It's really important for us to understand that
this contingent, these factions exist and they
are very radical. To pretend that they don't
exist doesn't do us any good. It achieves
nothing to pretend they don't exist. So
let's look at some clips and remember that the
real point here is that it's a pro Trump rally
to support Donald Trump stealing the
election from Joe Biden. Now ostensively,
this is a political rally saying Trump actually
won. Let's figure out how to take it. OK,
that's crazy. But that's ostensibly what this is.
But the way in which the Trump was rigged stuff
overlaps with anti vaccine nonsense. It
overlaps with anti-Semitism. Of course,
it overlaps with anti science ideology. It's
important to understand the sort of Venn diagram
because it confirms much of what conspiracy
experts have told us. I've interviewed many
conspiracy experts on the show and they almost
unanimously say some conspiracy theories seem
benign. Flat Earth, for example. You believe
the earth is flat. You can't really do anything
with that. You're not going to be able to push
people off the edge because there is no edge,
et cetera. But the point is that certain people
are just more prone to believe conspiracies.
And so when we say flat earth is benign, OK,
but those same people are predisposed to believe
other stuff that is more dangerous and has
more real world implications. So let's get
right into it. Here is one speaker referring
to the deceptively named biological agent known
as a vaccine. That's a quote. Take a listen.
Does not comply. If you don't want to take an
experimental biological agent deceptively named a
vaccine, you must not allow yourself to be coerced
if you are living in fear of a non lethal virus
simply by the same cheap, ordinary medicines used
across the world. When you know something to be
false, you must reject it, period. When you know
something to be true, you must stand up for it and
you must be willing to fight for it. I urge you to
mark this day, this moment as a united return
of our nation to the eternal fight for freedom,
a commitment to integrity, a resolve to seek the
truth in all arenas and to always act upon it.
Americans, God bless America. OK, so that's
pro Trump steal the election insanity
merged with anti VAX conspiracies. That's one
example as to how these groups interact. All
right. Here is pro Trump's steal the election
stuff, merging with more general anti-communist
Hugo Chavez conspiracy theories,
which we've heard before.
Who knows that Sokoya Smartmatic and that company
was founded by Hugo Chavez in communist Venezuela.
Step three, your vote, your votes were exported.
And then, of course, much of this also combining
with the anti science stuff that directly leads
to covid deaths. And it's all kind of wrapped
up in this clip with religiosity because I guess
Jesus would say, don't wear a mask. You tell me.
So what I'm asking you to do right now is to do
the great reset in a good way. OK, we're going
to reframe it. Last night, about one hundred and
fifty of us went into Whole Foods and we dressed
up like people that aren't idiots hiding from a
virus that's not deadly. We did not wear a mask.
Who here is up to the task of not
wearing a mask? I ask you again,
who here is up to the task of not.
Wearing a mask, Jesus is king, and it's
time to let freedom ring, ladies and gentlemen.
So that's, I guess, claiming that the word of God
is not to wear masks during a pandemic. And that
same guy also claimed that covid tests are fake.
What that even means, I don't
know. But let's take a listen.
The PCR tests are fake. The covid-19 PCR
tests are fake. And if you go to my podcast,
you can hear interviews. You can hear the founder
of the PCR test carryforwards explaining to you
the PCR tests are supposed to be calibrated at 17.
Someone should write this down 17 to 20 cycles.
Those are calibrated at 40 cycles. What does that
mean? It means that it's like your speedometer
is telling you you're driving 400 miles an
hour when you're driving seven miles an hour.
So the covid tests are fake.
That's that's actually a new one.
And then we get into the anti-Semitism.
Now, it's about George Soros, a Jewish
man secretly controlling Supreme Court justice
is just the typical anti-Semitic dog whistle.
Our next speaker is one of the most fiery
activists I've ever known. She's tireless.
She's relentless. She will do research.
She's the only person I know who does.
She watches George Soros speeches for fun. But you
know what happens when you look one of those up?
She found he was talking about Chief Justice
John Roberts. Like George Soros owned them
and they weren't retweeted it for she gets this
information because she never stops fighting.
George Soros is controlling John Roberts.
George Soros is the real puppet master
of the chief justice of the Supreme Court.
That's the idea. And as I've said before,
you have to know what you're listening for. That's
the thing about dog whistles. It's much like when
you blow a dog whistle, the dog has ears tuned
to hear it. So they hear the whistle. It's the
same thing with these anti-Semitic tropes
and dog whistles. You have to understand
the context and what what they're referring
to. And then lastly, Alex Jones doesn't need
much of an introduction. Not looking good, not
sounding good, but saying very, very wild things.
We don't quietly take the election
fraud. We don't quietly take the scam
and believe their B.S. We've seen the evidence
the system has had to desperately engage in this
gambit to maintain control. But this will be
their Waterloo. This will be their destruction.
Whatever happens to President Trump in 15
days, he is still the elected president of this
republic and we do not recognize the communist
Chinese agent, Joe Biden, or his controllers.
Yeah. So that's again, it's either a character
that he's playing or a very, very sick guy. So my
question, I sort of have a short term
and a medium term question on these folks
short term is what do they do tomorrow
when the vote will have been certified?
The electoral vote will have been counted
in the House and Senate for Joe Biden.
What do they do on January 20th when Trump
leaves? Do they get violent? What happens? That's
the short term question. The more medium term
question is, do these people even stay engaged
with the political world? Many of them were never
engaged before Trump. They were sort of they sort
of joined politics directly into the Trump cult.
And I don't know the answer as to whether they
just get out of politics or they stay. And much
of it might depend on what Trump does for the
next two or four years. Does Trump remain engaged
in politics or does he disappear to wherever will
allow him and just kind of play golf and sit
around questions we don't yet have answers to?
And we'll continue covering this
and these events on our Instagram,
where you can find us at David Pakman, The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.